Speaker 1: Well, guys, for better or for worse.
Alex Jones is now very, very upset with me.
It's hard to think of a bigger endorsement
than Alex Jones thinking What I'm doing is
very bad.
Alex Jones devoting a 12 minute segment to
me now.
Four minutes was him selling some kind of
vitamin.
So we're not going to look at that, but at
least eight minutes devoted to me making me
out to be a predator of some kind.
Let's just jump right into this thing.
This is truly beyond belief.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 3: Look at that.
That is a frickin predator right there who
thinks he's smarter than you think she's better
than you and he's going to beat you, he thinks
Pacman never talked to the new world order.
Pacman never got to try to get hired by the
gesture group because Pac-Man is a loser.
Speaker 1: Isn't this the absolute best thing?
I mean, it's it's wild.
Speaker 3: Is a sellout.
He's not a real man.
Speaker 1: And remember, who did I sell out
to?
They never tell me
Speaker 3: he's not a knight at the round
table.
That's true.
Speaker 1: I'm not a knight at the round that
that actually is accurate.
Speaker 3: He didn't actually have a real
discussion with the power structure he worships.
See, I said no to the evil power structure.
Not because I was a hero.
Because I had God.
I had a connection to the infinite.
I knew this was a failure.
This was not good.
I didn't join with God and justice because
I was a good person.
Why I did it, because I had discernment and
wanted to be with God
Speaker 1: and the still images of me so that
I that are supposed to, I guess, be ominous
or pretty funny.
Sam seeder texted me, Let me tell you exactly
what Sam Sam's comment about this was so funny.
He said, It's really weird.
He does a close up of your face and tries
to make you seem evil, but no offense.
You look like a teenager from the neighborhood
who would carry an old lady's groceries for
her home from the supermarket.
And yet, and yet I'm made out to look very
evil.
Now, what's really funny is I don't even know
why this clip triggered Alex Jones so much.
It was one of the voicemails I played where
people were saying, Do you think if things
got bad, you'd be able to get out of the country?
For some reason, it really triggered Alex
Jones show.
Speaker 3: This is just a snapshot of the
bizarreness of acting like a tape call is
a call and a with it and talking to it because
you're so scared to actually talk to people.
Speaker 1: Now understand what Alex Jones
is saying.
He's saying, I want you guys know we do a
voicemail on every show.
When I do a voicemail, I say it's a voicemail.
I'm not pretending it's a real call.
So Alex Jones is lying to you.
That might come as a shock.
He also says I don't take live calls on the
show.
We take a dozen live calls every single week.
I mean, you guys all know that we take live
calls all the time, so the entire premise
here is a lie.
Speaker 3: And give them the power being live.
Speaker 1: We do it all the time
Speaker 3: for the left always claims Jones
has fake callers.
Jones has fake reviews because they're fake
because they rig everything, because they're
so scared they can't control it all.
Speaker 1: We've been taking live calls every
week for a decade
Speaker 3: and then to hear, to be sure, the
Rasmussen poll
Speaker 1: OK.
So then he continues going into this stuff
and then he goes back to the personal attacks,
which I have to tell you.
I find them funnier than anything else.
Speaker 3: So they're doing this to us.
Classical corporate takeover censorship.
Debunking arrest.
Tyranny and collapsing.
And then he's talking about them as victims.
Rather than talk about a fantasy, talk about
a simulation.
He's in his job, but he knows it's not a simulation.
He loves this for his little groveling followers
that actually drink this Kool-Aid.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's an attack on you guys
he's talking about.
You guys continue.
But maybe some people in the audience have
a different perspective on the bonus show
today.
We will talk about the fight.
Speaker 3: That's enough.
Oh, the bonus show where you want to make
money and everybody else, it makes money to
fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: There is no greater endorsement
for the bonus show than Alex Jones hating
it, guys.
I can't think of a better endorsement of everything
we're doing than the fact that Alex Jones
hates it.
I really can't.
Speaker 3: If I was telling my children who
not to be, it's that guy.
I mean, he's a disgrace and I don't say that
like God, I feel good about myself.
No, he makes me feel pathetic.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, that's interesting.
That's I mean, we should, Alex.
If if seeing me makes him feel pathetic, that
would be something to explore in psychotherapy.
I think that that would.
I think psychoanalysis would have a lot to
say about that.
Speaker 3: Look at those eyes, man, that's
that dude is gone.
He's a gentleman.
Speaker 1: So anyway, that this is basically
just an unbelievable thing now.
A couple a couple of really funny things about
this.
Number one, I only got two messages in response
to this.
That's how diminished Alex Jones is right
now.
In the past, if when he was on real platforms
and he would do like a, you know, eight minute
attack video it would create a frenzy.
I got two messages because I don't know that
anyone's watching Alex Jones anymore.
Secondly, I bet Alex Jones has no memory of
the fact that he and I have met in person,
and we talked for close to a half hour at
the Talkers new media seminar some years ago.
Alex Jones, me and the hosts of Free Talk
Live Ian Freeman and Mark Edge.
Yeah, now I believe it is under arrest.
The four of us just had a completely normal
conversation about the business of media,
and I'm sure he doesn't even remember that.
But at the time, he wasn't acting like I gave
off predator vibes.
He seemed fine chatting with me, and I'm sure
if you.
It probably made no impression on him.
I mean, listen, who was I to Alex Jones at
the time?
But just an interesting, interesting little
tidbit, but an incredible endorsement when
Alex Jones is this upset with you?
You know, you know that you must be doing
something that is resonating with at least
some people.
So there it is.
Alex Jones very unhappy with me.
We'll have clips from this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.
You can also find the clip on my Instagram
at David Pakman.